Banners glow bright on the rafters tonight
Not a Lakers fan to be seen
Coach Scott calls isolation,
And Swaggy P's setting the screen
The fans are howling, there 's a media storm outside...
Couldn't get the win. Heaven knows I tried...
Don't let them in, don't let them see
Be the Mamba you always have to be
Shaquille O'Neal, don't let him knoooooow...
Well, now he knoooooows!
Let it tank, let it tank
Going 8 for 24
Let it tank, Let it tank
Fade away and shoot some more
I don't care
If I'm overpaid
Let the Spurs rage on
Getting old never bothered them anyway!
It's funny how much distance
We have from winning it all
And defenders that couldn't control me
Now just steal the ball!
If I retire, what would I do?
Maybe I'll star in Frozen 2
Do what I want, no rules for meee! I'm Kooobe!
Let it tank, Let it tank
Get a pick hopefully top 5
Let it tank, let it tank
Without Phil, why even try?
Here I stand
And here I'll play
If my legs hold up!
My power forward broke his shin in his first
game
Now I could not even tell you half of our
players names
And one thought bulges like a disc inside
Steve Nash
No more back-to-backs,
The past is in the past!
LET IT TANK, LET IT TANK!
I'll never get that sixth
Let it tank, let it tank
Dwight Howard's a soft-ass B*tch!
Here I stand
King of L.A.
Laker Nation!
Getting old never bothered me anyway...
BLEACHER  REPORT MEDIA LAB 2015